the Joe Rogan experience ooh baby
they're fast coming down right into your
walls out of your mouth and everything
loves just - on the ground
Oh so what's he gonna do now see you run
to the river run to the sea sift through
the rubble and search the debris but you
won't find anything if you don't find
peace oh so what's he gonna do now don't
wait til you - cuz you can always change
your mind and make your eyes - are you
still waiting outside
[Music]
baby mama didn't treat you right maybe
just in sleep last night you know I
don't give a damn why you wanna fry
oh so what you gonna do now don't wait
until you die cuz you cannot change your
mind and make it right so why are you
still waiting outside so come out from
the wiesen in my arms oh babe I know the
dark and how I can harm you yeah that my
conscience rip me apart to here's what
we're gonna do now
take all the carry the weight if it
breaks every Liam well that's what we're
gonna do now don't wait until you die
cuz you can always change your mind and
make it right
so why are you still waiting outside
still waiting outside
[Music]
[Applause]